this has to be your morning announcement
but listen up okay this has to come to
an end it's come to the point where it's
absolutely unbearable all right the
delicious uh devious lick trend on tick
tock needs to come to an end devious
licks devious licks just what is a
devious lick
the devious lick originally started on
tick tock as a viral challenge which
encouraged people to steal items from
school bathrooms
[Music]
wikipedia states that the devious lick
is also known as a diabolical lick a
dastardly lick or a nefarious look
in september the trend sped rapidly on
tick tock to the alarm of teachers and
parents alike
another viral tick-tock trend going in
the wrong direction it's happening in
our local schools so this trend you
might have heard of it it's called
devious licks and students have been
recording themselves vandalizing and
stealing school property i've heard
about that viral tick-tock trend going
around right now it's called devious
licks and it's now taking its toll on
another utah school it is costing murray
high school more than just money to
repair the damage the trend itself has
already resulted in the arrest of
several high school students in the
united states
snatching up school property wreaking
havoc in bathrooms stealing from
teachers and students somehow this is
the newest tick tock trend and after the
chaos of september school bathroom trend
a school in san antonio banned backpacks
from football games
[Music]
even more disturbing is that according
to a list circulating on social media
this trend is just one in a whole list
of escalating deviousness according to
the list october's challenge is to slap
a staff member
whilst january's disturbing challenge is
to jab a female in the breast
it's happening on campuses here and
across the nation while tick-tock says
it has banned the so-called devious
licks challenge and is removing the
videos posted some students say it's too
late the damage is done although
teachers and parents have been talking
to twitter and tick tock in an effort to
stop the spread of the videos the trend
is no sign of slowing down
who knows where this trend will lead to
next
[Music]
you